[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
In this video, we're going to
take a look at a cool trick
using dry ice and bubbles.
Then we'll try and use the same principles,
and see if we can make bubbles
that are full of colored smoke.
[Music]
I've seen dry ice vapor being
used to fill bubbles before,
and it makes a sort of milky-white,
not quite see through bubble,
that when it pops,
it just releases a bunch of carbon
dioxide gas, and it looks really cool.
Steve Spangler had a video
where he showed how he did that.
I wanted to try using the
same basic setup that he did,
and see if we can recreate his results.
Then I want to see if we can use
similar techniques to use the smoke
from a smoke ball to
make colored bubbles.
Not just the white that
we'll get with the carbon dioxide,
but I want to see if we can really get
some like rainbow bubbles going on.
That should be pretty fun.
Here's the basic idea.
Dry ice in a container with some water
will cause vapors to travel down the tube,
through our nozzle into our bubble soap.
Hopefully, making bubbles
that are full of dry ice vapors.
We'll then try a couple different
methods to get smoke from a smoke
bomb to fill bubbles the same way.
We've got a little plastic
container with a lid on it.
This lid, if you don't
put the handle down,
does a very nice job of popping
on and off with no pressure at all,
and that's what we want for anything
that's going to have dry ice in it.
We are going to have a hose running
out that will relieve some pressure.
But it is dry ice.
We don't want it sealed in a container
with a lid doesn't come off.
Our hose is 7/16 inch hose,
and we're going to try drilling a hole
into the side of our container,
just very slightly smaller than that.
So, when we put the hose in, it will
just kind of keep itself wedged in place.
[Music]
This container doesn't drill super well.
I'm just going to patch that up.
Try again a little bit
slower on the other side.
[Music]
Let's try this again.
Hopefully-- hopefully, it doesn't
just keep cracking or we'll just end up with
an entire box made of electrical
tape, with a hole punched into it.
[Music]
Okay, this style drillbit seems to
cut into the plastic much more easily.
Of course, that's not quite the right size.
So now, we're going to try
and widen it just a little bit.
[Music]
That is working great!
Hoses attached.
I can pull it out if I really try, but it
does seem to stay in fairly nicely.
Second time's the charm.
I've got this little
plumbing extension piece.
It's designed for switching from a type
of hose to something that threads on.
We're just going to use
this as our bubble nozzle.
So will fit this onto our hose,
and now we can dip
this into our bubble fluid,
and hopefully, bubbles should come out.
We've got a couple kinds of bubble
fluid we're going to test out.
This is just some water
with some soap mixed into it,
and then I've got actual bubble fluid,
and I'm just going to try both of these.
See what kinds of results I get.
[Music]
That's-- that's some bubbles.
Let's try the actual bubble soap.
[Music]
I guess probably not.
Too surprisingly, real bubble
soap gives us better bubbles
than trying to mix up our own version.
There are some really good
recipes for DIY bubble soap,
but I do think it's pretty easy
to use the premade stuff.
It's not expensive, so we're
just going to be using that today.
[Music]
We've got our container.
Here's a pitcher full of warm water.
Now, we're going to take a piece
of dry ice, drop it into our container,
put the lid on but not seal it,
so, it's still comes off nice and easily.
Not close down, which
makes it grip really hard.
Vapor coming out of
the nozzle just like we like.
[Music]
Take the lid off, and that stops,
and in the bubbles and...
Oh, that works really well.
[Music]
It's great.
Because the nozzle has threads on it,
I think it does a good job
of holding bubble soap for a while,
so we get a good amount
of bubbles out of this.
[Music]
My fingers covered with soap.
So, I'm actually hitting the bubbles,
but it just kind of bounces off them.
[Music]
Oh, that's-- that's good too. Get that.
This little contraption is easy to
throw together, and it works quite well.
The dry ice vapor is starting
to slow down now
because our water has
cooled down considerably.
But while it was still nice and hot,
we were pumping out
bubbles really nice quick.
It's really fun to watch them drop.
They're like translucence, but you
can't actually see through them.
They're just light coming through,
and you know, if you've
got a nice cotton surface,
these do a really good job
of letting the bubbles be preserve
for a second to not popping immediately.
Or if you cover your hand in soap,
then usually, you can touch the bubbles
a little bit like that as well.
Now, we want to see if we can create
a similar effect using colored smoke.
So we'll try and light these off,
and see if we can get them to fill a bubble
the same way the dry ice vapor does.
So my first thought is that we
could maybe just take one of these
little smoke balls,
put it in a sealed
container with a small hole,
and the pressure that builds
from the smoke coming out
might be enough to just blow air powerful
enough to blow a bubble on its own.
Let's build a little container that will
hold these, and then drill a hole
into it and see if that's true.
To make our little impromptu
smoke pressure chamber,
I've just got this little piece of PVC,
the smoke ball fits right in the side,
and then I've got a
couple of pieces of wood
that I can just tape one to the bottom,
and tape one is sort
of a hinge on the top.
That way, I can light the smoke
ball, drop it in, and hold this down.
And that should give us a decent seal.
We can see if enough smoke
comes out to blow a bubble.
[Music]
There we go.
That won't be a 100% perfect seal
but I think it's going to be good
enough that we can see
if this concept is going to work.
If it builds up enough pressure that it
can blow the smoke out in one direction,
hopefully, that will be enough to
blow some bubbles full of smoke.
To help to direct the smoke flow,
I'm going to drill a small hole the same
way we did on the big one,
and attach a small piece of tubing to it.
[Music]
Here's a little contraption.
So the plan, we light the smoke ball,
drop it in, throw the lid down on,
and see how much
smoke we get out of here.
[Music]
Quite a bit of smoke,
good amount of color coming out.
The question is whether or not that has
enough pressure to blow any bubbles.
This bubble one has
several different bubble holes.
I'm going to try for this one
right her,e because it seems
like a good size for the hose we've got.
[Music]
Well, my timing wasn't great.
But that still seemed like it just
popped the bubbles like immediately.
Try this again,
and you can time this better.
[Music]
It's not really blowing
the bubble soap at all.
So I think, we're gonna have to come
up with a different method to do this.
A lot of smoke does come out
the nozzle but for whatever reason,
it's not really blowing
anything at the bubbles.
I didn't even see the bubble soap
start to move, and most of the time,
it just popped it immediately.
So let's move on to design number two.
Since this isn't putting out very much
pressure, I want to try something else
where I build a device,
fill it with smoke,
and then use my own lungs to blow air in,
and have that travel through the container,
and out the other side.
Cut my piece of PVC pipe, and I've got
two round pieces of thin plywood,
and I think I'm going to make those
into the top and bottom.
So I'll tape one on so it's
completely sealed on in,
and the other one,
I'll add sort of a hinge
so I can just open it,
drop the smoke ball in, close it again.
This tape here is just to sort
of work as an improv gasket.
It's not as good as a real gasket,
or even a Proto putty seal
but we don't need this to be 100% airtight.
We just need to contain
most of the smoke.
That's our goal.
Okay, that's looking good.
Now, let's drill the hole back.
[Music]
Perfect.
Now, we need to drill the hole
for the front piece of PVC.
This spade bit is going to make a hole.
That's just a little bit too large.
So after we put our piece of PVC in,
we're going to have to
secure it with some tape.
[Music]
When I blow into this tube,
It goes down into the chamber,
up through the chamber,
and out through the nozzle.
So before we add any smoke,
let's see if this is going
to work for blowing bubbles.
Just take our bubble wand,
and see what we can do.
[Music]
We are getting bubble
when we blow into the tube,
and hold the bubble wand
in front of the nozzle.
I think it's time to add some smoke.
[Music]
That's a bubble full of smoke.
Ah! Look at those bubbles.
[Music]
Now,. I'm just gonna keep doing this
over and over till I run out of smoke balls.
[Music]
I'm pretty sure that some of the smoke
powder that comes off actually
causes the bubbles to rupture.
You have to get just the right amount.
If you wait too long, then there's really
not going to be much color left.
If you do it too soon, the chemicals
seem to just destroy the soap bubbles,
which is problem I've
had a couple of times now.
[Music]
That's the look.
Oh man.
[Music]
>> Start.
I don't feel so good.
>> Dry ice bubbles work really well,
and smoke bomb
bubbles work pretty well.
Not quite as uniformly
or smoothly as the dry ice,
but we did get a lot of really good results.
That's something that I really
want to take to another level.
I want to see if we can soup that up.
I'm thinking maybe a device
that will automatically blow six
different colors of smoke at once.
So we can just sort of have
a rainbow cascade of different
smoke-filled bubbles falling down.
That might be a video you
want to look for in the future.
Guys, we've got more for you to see.
That box up at the top will
take you directly to our last video,
and you should go check that out.
The box at the bottom will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next.
If you hit this bomb in the middle,
you'll be subscribed to the channel
so you never miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see in the next one.
Talk to you then.